Let's say you're socially anxious.
Okay,
so what happens when you're socially
anxious?
You go to a party,
your heart's beating.
Why?
The party is a monster.
Because it's judging you and it's
judging you.
It's putting you low down the dominance
hierarchy because that's what a negative
judgment is and that interferes with
your sexual soul success.
And that means that you're being harshly
evaluated by nature itself,
right?
So you are confronting the dragon of
chaos when you go into the social
situation.
And so what do you do?
You like this?
So you hunch over and that's low
dominance.
I'm no threat.
It's like,
Whoa,
that's not going to get you very far,
you know,
but that's a logical thing to do in,
in the,
in the face of a tyrant.
So I'm no threat.
You know,
you look at the king and your dad,
I'm no threat,
I'm hunched over.
And then what's happening internally?
How are,
what are people thinking about me?
What are people thinking about me or am
I looking stupid?
Am I looking foolish?
Geez,
I'm awkward.
I hate being here,
man.
I'm sweating too much.
It's all internalized,
right?
It's all self focused,
the,
I isn't work,
the eye isn't working.
What do you tell people?
Stop.
Don't stop thinking about yourself
because you can't.
It's like,
don't think of a white elephant,
white elephant,
White,
elephant,
elephant.
You can't tell someone to stop thinking
about something because they get caught
in the loop.
What you do with socially anxious people
as you say,
look at other people.
Look at them.
Right?
Why?
Because if you look at them,
you can tell what they're thinking and
then you,
unless you're.
Unless you're terribly socialized and
some people are,
some people have no social skills and so
the reason they can't go to a party is
because they don't even know how to
introduce themselves.
Like they're just no one ever taught
them how to behave and so they're really
good candidates for behavior therapy
because you walk them through the
process of how you actually manifest the
procedures that are associated with
social acceptability.
But most people aren't like that.
They have the ability.
So if they're really introverted in high
in neuroticism,
they can usually talk quite well to
someone one on one.
Why?
Because they look at them all.
If I look at you,
it's another thing to do.
If you're ever speaking to a group of
people,
never speak to the group of people there
that doesn't exist.
You talk to individuals and then they
reflect for you the entire group because
they're all in trained.
You look at one person,
they broadcast to you what everyone's
thinking and you know how to talk to one
person.
So it's easy.
So as soon as you focus on the person,
not you,
you push your attention outward.
Use Your I push your attention outward
and you start watching.
Well then all your automatic mechanisms
kick in and you start being awkward
because if we're talking and I'm looking
here,
I don't know what you're going to do
next and I'm going to put disjunctions
into the like.
They're like a bad chords and the melody
of our,
of our conversation.
And the reason is I'm not paying
attention.
So that's why the I is the thing at the
top of the pyramid.
It's like the thing that enables you to
win the set of all possible dominance
hierarchies is the I pay attention.
Pay Attention.
That's the critical issue.
That's why the Egyptians worshiped
horace.
That's why horace was the thing that
rescued Osiris from the,
from the depths.
It's the capacity to pay attention.
What do you pay attention to?
Most?
What?
Your right hemisphere signals as
anomalous.
It attracts your attention.
It's like this isn't going quite right.
I'm not looking at that wrong.
That's what you look at.
What's not going right,
because that's.
See,
that's the terrible monster that might
eat you,
but it's also the place you get all the
information,
so that's why it's useful to have
discussions with your enemies because
they will tell you things you do not
know and that's such a great thing
because if you don't know them well,
you're not very smart,
are you?
You know there may be a time when you go
somewhere,
that's the thing you need to know and
maybe your enemy will kill you.
Why you're such a fool,
you know,
and a bunch of other things that aren't
true to,
but even one thing that's accurate,
it's like,
yeah,
thanks very much man.
Maybe I'll do some work on that and I
won't have to carry that forward.
So.
And then that's part of the reason again
why the terrible predator.
It's always the terrible Predator that
has the gold.
It's like it's the person who delivers
the message you do not want to hear.
So it's rough,
it's rough,
but it doesn't matter.
Life is rough.